ви знаєте товариство тут все виглядає в
цій залі і смішно і грішно
понад рік монобільшість активно захищала
право опзж бути у цьому залі активно
захищала того самого чоловіка Нестора
Шуфрича щоби він був і на посаді голови
комітету нічого вони голосували тому що
у нас тут існує ширка по суті між
монобільшістю і опзж давайте будемо
чесні ще 13 місяців тому було подано
проєкт постанови про те що колишні з
опзж не мають бути Ані на посадах Ані
мають бути присутні у цій залі але що
розказували монобільшість що у нас що у
вас конструктивна співпраця з опзж на
відміну з іншими фракціями а кілька
місяців тому було подано проект
постанови від європейської солідарності
щоби Шуфрича було знято з посади голови
комітету свободи слова Але ж ні пане
руслане ви сказали що на це немає
абсолютно ніяких підстав Ну на жаль так
само як і наші спецслужби понад два роки
просто ну взагалі не бачили по підстав
щоби розправлятися з опзж а рік навіть
не бачили конкретних кримінальних
підстав щоби ці речі вирішувати Але
добре що дійшло до цього зараз хоча ми
бачимо що в ПСЖ красиво і далі під
голосовує за все що в мене більш і скаже
але ми би хотіли наголосити на іншому
замість того щоб головою комітету
ставали люди які пропонували собак
продавати то насправді Комітет з питань
свободи слова це є комітет який має бути
представлений і очолений представниками
опозиції і оскільки єдина опозиційна
сила у цій залі цієї європейська
Солідарність ми вимагаємо щоби
найближчим часом було розглянуте це
питання і на чолі комітету з питань
свободи слова бо представник опозиції
тобто європейської солідарності і
давайте ми тепер чесно все-таки будемо
говорити опзж та інші заборонні партії А
також їхні представники